good morning everyone we're all
scattered around so it looks a much
smaller group than it actually is but
welcome on this wonderfully rainy day
it's a perfect day for a conference
nobody's tempted to go outside and so
you're all going to be captive in this
room for the rest of the day
my name is John icky Barclay and I'm the
director of the South Asian Institute at
Columbia University it's my very great
pleasure to welcome you all to today's
conference which is titled as you know
from the postcards that we printed
beyond security Democratic contest
Asians in Bangladesh and Pakistan which
I've been organizing now it seems for
probably for my entire life or at least
it feels like it but I've organized it
with aquas Eddie and Dena Siddiqui both
of whom I hear today and before I get
started on sounding sort of like NPR and
start thanking the John D and Catherine
T MacArthur I'd like to announce a very
important change to our program
scheduled this afternoon the
introduction to our plenary speaker
Sarah Hassan will be given by University
professor of the humanities guide
through Spivak I'm very pleased and very
grateful to her that she was able to
agree to participate in the conference
particularly since she's on leave this
year and we're taking her away from her
own work for an afternoon and giving her
very little notice and asking her to
work with us conference today is
co-sponsored by several Columbia campus
partners and all of you familiar with
Columbia know that I'm now going to just
rattle off a series of acronyms but let
me begin with the Department of History
the Department of Middle East South
Asian and African Studies and now the
Institute's the IR Cpl the Institute for
religion culture and public life ear wag
the Institute for Research on women and
gender I serve the institute for social
and economic research policy and the
School of International and public
affairs in particular I'd like to thank
professors mark massage the kaviraj to
mitchell al stepan mark taylor Beth
Pavan Ellie's idea Hartman Sudhir
Venkatesh Peter Burman and university
provost and Dean of SEPA John cotesworth
outside but linked to the Columbia orbit
I'd also like to thank Thomas Hanson who
is at Stanford I was going to say who's
no longer with us and then I realized it
sounded very dire definitely with us
just not at Columbia and Christophe
Jafra low for arranging extraordinary
things in subway stations there are a
number of people who supplied crucial
support to us why we were organizing the
details and finding funding to host some
20 scholars from different parts of the
world and without the support of dr.
Ezra raise our hand mr. mone Masha Cola
both of whom will be with us this
evening and tomorrow evening
this conference would simply not have
come together in the way that it did and
I want to publicly thank them for their
help we are also indebted to Pakistan
International Airlines as well for
agreeing to subsidize at very short
notice
air traveled to the conference for one
of the key organizers at where's Eddie
who because of the American consulate
didn't get his visa in enough time to
teach this dumb but P ia was gracious
enough to make it possible through him
to come here at very short notice and
for that I'd like to thank Tariq Yaseen
County manager in New York for PIAA for
his help in arranging actors travel aqua
has been an invaluable colleague at the
Institute since he joined Columbia as a
visiting professor in fall 2010 and it
is my very great pleasure right now to
embarrass him with what I'm going to say
I must acknowledge his intellectual
contribution to the conference act but
please don't go away and his really
untiring efforts to make it happen we're
all thrilled that he's rejoining us in
spring 2012 and fall 2012 to finish out
his tenure is visiting professor and I
am particularly happy that he was able
to come to a conference that he has been
so instrumental in organizing before I
turn the podium over to ambassador
abdullah hussein Haroon who is the
permanent representative of pakistan to
the united nations
I need to tell you a short story extend
my most sincere thanks to the ambassador
not only because he's been able to take
time out from his busy schedule to open
the conference and to come here tomorrow
to introduce our second plenary speaker
which is more than we would have
expected but it is also the case that
the ambassador has been instrumental in
gathering support for the conference
from the moment that we began let me
tell you a story
about a year ago I took him out for
dinner took him to a restaurant that I
chose and I didn't quite know that he is
the gourmand that he is and I happened
to take him to a restaurant that was not
particularly his favorite and I then fed
him food there was not particularly of
his choosing and I would completely have
expected him to tell me to just go away
and not bother him ever again not come
anywhere near him again instead of which
he invited me to lunch
spectacular lunch I must say my eyes
were bigger than my stomach I couldn't
eat as much as I wanted to
spectacular lunch made it possible then
for me to be introduced to two of our
central benefactors for this conference
and has agreed subsequently to host a
special dinner for some of the
participants tomorrow I'm very very
grateful for all this assistance I don't
know what it says about india-pakistan
relations that I could buy him a meal II
didn't like and in a restaurant he
didn't like and he would still then
agree to help me out so much but it
certainly says volumes for Pakistani
generosity I thank you very very much
ambassador Haroon has served as
permanent representative of Pakistan to
the UN since September 2008 educated at
the University of Karachi he began his
career in public service as election
coordinator for the Pakistan Muslim
League he has served as a member of the
cynth provincial assembly a speaker of
the provincial assembly and as the
leader of the opposition and he was
appointed as a delegate to the UN
General Assembly
apart from public service he has also
been active in social and philanthropic
work and has executive experience in
business
educational institutions clearly and a
charity organizations and please join me
in welcoming ambassador heron to
Colombia where he will officially open
this conference I hope ladies and
gentlemen all the distinguished would be
enough as a starter it's a great
pleasure to be here I would like to
recognize a friend who would hate me
giving away his age though it's a he and
not a she emphasizes there was travel
from Pakistan for this conference I know
there are time limitations and I would
love to ramble on but the way I'm going
to take this up is to say to you that
India which was never called India in
history but the subcontinent has had an
amazing and absolutely amazing history
I'm not even going into the fact that it
collided with Asia and sent the highest
mountains up in the world and that the
coffers of jith wrong when bead
necklaces made out of seashells which
they find around strewn around their
fields it's at 14 and 16 thousand feet
above sea level but I come to the point
to say that when the Aryans came in
through the passes of the Himalayas they
pushed the indigenous population the
Dravidians
to what they considered much like the
Maginot Line was in the Second World War
beyond the Cauvery and it's where we get
the word barbarian from this is sort of
thing you'd expect from the anglo-saxons
to talk about the East
but it is in fact the Aryans who they
thought that the Dravidians talked too
much and they called them indigenously
the Berbers now that's where barbarian
comes from not the Berbers of North
Africa as is conceived by some here that
everything is credited to the
Mediterranean but why I say this to you
that what came in subsequently was to
have an impact on history Central Asian
/ Caucasians and they changed India
completely started off approximately six
to seven thousand years ago with the
Vedas being their guiding light and the
vedantic Creed took over most of North
and Central India what I would say about
the Dravidian races that despite the
fact they were apt to talk too much
there were people of peace and there
were times though of course the Ahrens
claimed that they had made it by then
when the indus valley civilization
flourished with the armenians the
Babylonians the early egyptians the only
difference was that the other empires
were rested by force and violence and
the Indus civilization has not yet
discovered in many sites even a knife
let alone a sword and yet these were
oligarchies before the Mediterranean and
Greece had its oligarchies in Athens and
surprisingly completely vegetarian and
it was the Caucasians and Central Asians
who introduced animal sacrifice to the
subcontinent it's a very interesting
fact also because from then spread many
religions India much later ma
much later took its name from the Indus
I and II became sin for end for anything
you could think of and the interesting
fact that was that despite the fact but
ISM Hinduism Jainism Zoroastrianism Jews
Judaism Islam Christianity everything
ultimately Sikhism went down in India
Indian never changed its colors faith
did not change it colors in fact faiths
changed in India and you'll be surprised
that when we talk of Islam within the
subcontinent and we talk of Islam or
Christianity within the subcontinent or
even many others and of course today
two-thirds of the world all but less
perhaps 40% of the world derives its
faith from India not from the three
great monotheistic religions it has had
an amazing consequence in the world and
one of the reasons is that what came
from India was not claimed to be the
work of gods but it described gods and
the beauty is the ever-changing aspect
of Hinduism which is not monotheistic in
any way by the way the first time it was
decided to put together the Hindu races
they had numbered about 500 then they
discovered that they needed to do it
politically and it was in the late 19th
century and the reason for it was the
creation of the Indian political
movement called the Indian National
Congress and it was originated by an
Englishman like everything is in this
world ultimately the interesting reason
to this is that all these raised races
lived within some sort of strain it's
like the universe you never know why the
planets don't collide incessantly but
they don't so things work their way out
but I remember they sort of
I completely remember in fact the fact
that people would talk about how Islam
was not pure in subcontinent and some
would grimace and say well Christianity
was never the same ever since it came
here and on and on and I believe this
arrest chinnan's changed to becoming
power sales as they got to searching and
coaching I beg your pardon and various
areas and the reason for this is that it
impacts so completely that and why I say
this to you is coming to the point
finally when I was at a wedding off what
mr. Saurez will tell you more about in
his neck of the woods
the jart community I saw them doing
strange things and I said what was this
I've never seen this in any Muslim
wedding before they said we're not
Muslims were Jarts first and the Hindu
jalsa the Muslim jobs or we'll do the
same thing so you have to understand
that and I said absolutely I mean the
breed the the branding which is so
important in the marketing of products
in the world today it seems to be even
stronger in north where northwestern
india and pakistan so what you expect
when you talk about this is that they're
basically the mansion had many British
India had many rooms we've walled up a
few between ourselves there's absolutely
no difference
believe me in terms of so India has a
thousand traditions a million different
ways of enacting culture but the truth
of the matter is it is simply
homogeneous and it worked not just their
subconscious but also from Central Asia
and the Afghan beyond the Permian and
beyond the Irrawaddy in Burma and the
British had it right somehow that's why
they found it's so easy with barely
twenty thousand Englishmen to run
so I then come to the point why we're
here today with this little brief
introduction that finally the Muslims
woke up and we owe this awakening to
Bengal Bengal was that tract of land
which was found to be the most
attractive by the British it was the
richest or one of the richest provinces
of India with tremendous outputs and in
20 years it entered the worst famine in
its history because everything had been
so exploited that nothing was left and
nothing remained there and the reason
that famine was brought about because
there was an ingenious way of earning
money and that was my crowing poppy
instead of what was natural food
products and with that poppy China was
encouraged with his teeming millions to
use it and that started the richest load
in history based on opium products and
unfortunately the problem
well the Bengal suffered completely it
was devastated and couldn't feed itself
millions died during nine million or
something at one stage then came up a
group of people who thought that they
might do better as rabindranath tagore
from Hindu Bengal have this tremendous
renaissance and I'm going to mention
another name which history has more or
less denied because anything that was
not through west after the second world
war and the victor spoils was considered
to be ugly evil and unnecessary and one
of the greatest men in history of the
subcontinent
let me tell you that the history of the
subcontinent would have been different
there would've been no Pakistan if
Subash Chandra Bose of Bengal had had
his way as president of the Indian
National Congress
and people of smaller ilk like java lal
nehru and bara by patel had not cornered
him or squeezed him out with Gandhi's
help from the premier ranks of
leadership in undivided Indian British
India and the reason I say that is the
only man who united over two hundred
thousand troops against the British with
Muslims Hindus Sikhs Christians Jews
anything even take he United them nobody
has ever United the subcontinent the way
he United them and he had whatever he
thought but of course when you are on
the wrong side of the war then
unfortunately you do not get remembered
so well in history I believe that he was
one of the greatest again from then go
on and I one of the greatest aspects is
that being leader of his huge force his
number two was a Muslim general again by
the name of Kyani from the same area
where the current she was self the
Pakistan Army comes from so I remember
heaviness in history again two great
names and on the Muslim side there was
natural Islam a great thinker a great
poet there were many thusly Huck was a
great politician but the most astute and
greatest visionary mirjana Muslim Bengal
was the nabob Salim ala of taka and
Salim rod enjoined the entire Muslim
world together at his Dallas s and
Manzel in Dhaka and he said well if five
hundred Hindu races are homogeneous
today why can't we be one and that is
where the the seeds of the Muslim
movement in India were raised it led to
the first great movement first great
joint movement
between Hindu and Muslim which is the
Halawa the movement for the restoration
of Turkey's rights and principles though
of course I don't think so plan Hamid
quite required it being as he was but
anyway there it was a good joint
movement in India which led to then the
salt marches and many other things in
subsequent but it brought together
communities as you wouldn't even today
when you think of India Pakistan you
know and this is what happened when I
came to the United Nations
three-and-a-half years ago and said ah
you know it's gonna be some good
skirmishing and I said what skirmishing
he's no Indian Pakistan never talked to
each other is garnished and I said
really
and sometimes they throw Bangladesh in
for good sprinkling effect but the truth
of the matter is this is where I want to
get to is that we are basically in one
house by building walls between us
traditions culture bloodlines thoughts
nothing really changes and frankly all
we do is encourage the finger pointers
or the haters which they're always bound
to be many in society and that doesn't
change basically if that doesn't change
basically what are the perspectives
today this is what I've been telling my
friends and I mentioned them both with
great affection here about Momo is the
bangladesh ambassador very dear friend
of mine and now have you seen booray who
is the ambassador of India again a very
dear friend of mine and both and myself
and a few others have tried to work very
hard towards bringing together the
concept that made that subcontinent
unitedly great but coming to the present
positions as they lie they have been
tensions of course they'd be tensions
Bengal has an ever encroaching river
system when the rivers don't encroach
the sea intro
and comes in and I believe that the
pressure on land is the highest in the
world per capita and it gets worse even
when they're thinking of damning parts
of the Brahmaputra or the Ganges I still
don't think they're gonna get away with
water and the most interesting
observation was made by the emperor
Humayun
when he visited that neck of the woods
for an xing it and he found rivers
flowing in opposite directions and he
thought this is incredible well actually
what it was that when the sea comes in
from certain lower tri areas it seems
the rivers flow an opposite and he said
let's leave quickly this place seems to
be damned
and somehow it's got worse not better
but it produces incredible intelligence
in every aspect of every faith in and
one of the great aspects of it was that
my ancestors say that when the Indian
subcontinent was divided the interesting
part was that there were three sectors
which won direct action days actually
proved that they were going to do
something about it the first most
important Calcutta the second and of
lesser importance was left now and then
Karachi in sin and no other part of
India moved for that day so these three
were amongst the leadership of taking a
separate stand which would also never
have happened if as I should Jalal says
Neru had been a little more
accommodating to generous suggestions of
Muslims a personal family law being
accepted and he said we can't have two
set of rules and then promptly gave it
to Sheikh Abdullah in Kashmir when he
proposed the same because he wanted to
annex cash man so I don't know if we
left or we were pushed out but between
the two there is some history
I'm sure researchers are going to do
something about it or fleet the current
leadership in Bangladesh Haseena the
daughter of Sheikh Mujibur Rahman a man
of immaculate honesty what you don't
know when we met him after he was
released became prime minister of
Bangladesh in Canada he recounted that
when they came to take him away they
thought they were there to execute him
he didn't know what had been happening
he had no radio and he said where are
you taking me
and he recounted this himself to us and
they said we're sending you back home he
said where they said to Bangladesh and
he said the first thought that came to
my mind was what of Pakistan and this is
that's none of your business you just
leave which I think was grossly unfair
because he was the elected majority
leader of all Pakistan
unfortunately then he met a violent end
and nothing has been quite the same as
far as Pakistan goes perhaps the person
who did make sure that things would
divide with his famous statement which
you were there and we are here maybe it
was not meant to be divisive but it
certainly became very divisive also met
a violent end his progeny met a violent
end and today we are standing at the
crossroads I remember well I saved that
for tomorrow but young yet is our zest
and rooting against these y'all hug
government and fighting tooth and nail
for democracy democracy like everything
else in that subcontinent is not quite
what you think about it here I was with
Wolfensohn when he was president of the
World Bank and we looked out of his
windows to a day like this and he said
wet miserable day
I said that's the problem between you
not realizing what we're all about and
we're not realizing what you're all
about is what do you mean I said if this
was an with subcontinent today they will
be preparing sweetmeats and pakoras to
celebrate the day there would be a
cooling of senses in the earlier part of
the day spring would be in the air love
would be in the air at night you would
have perhaps the largest get-together of
lovers or husbands and wives or whatnot
and it'll be a great celebration if we
had a day like that in that part of the
world so I said no wonder you don't
understand us you hate it we love it so
you know there's and that is something
that is so true
in everything we call a science the
markers the parameters are basically
what you set out here in your pristine
loveliness I mean you know you don't
even get this stinking stench of drying
corpses or the dust filtering through
your eyes and your nose and your ears
unfortunately all that which perhaps
helps impair us making better decisions
are not quite witnessed here or felt
here so that you can see the difference
and why the thinking becomes so
different but it happens and we are
impaired by perhaps by many thoughts on
the subject
but the truth of the matter is we enjoy
its what Ian Forster said all of India
is a muddle and I I don't think he meant
to derogatory I think he brought about a
beautiful understanding of that model
because as I said like the universe it
seems to creep on and grow larger ever
more nagging see Janki looking very
worried about this so and it doesn't
seem to be getting anywhere it's more
reminiscing rather than historic well in
terms of history she wants to know about
security
favorite subject I think if you haven't
read it I wish I had brought a book but
I'll give you a copy perhaps they can
photocopy doubt a former Indian service
illa service officer wrote a book about
being chief secretary and political
agent and the border areas of Pakistan
when he retired he wrote this book and
it was not printed in Pakistan it was
printed in India and I circulated it to
the UN and specially to my American
friends in Washington and elsewhere and
if you read the book it's barely about
90 odd pages it's called the wandering
Falcon and Jamil who wrote the book I
think you need to read it if you want to
understand what you're dealing with
because a lot of people here seem to
take the standard point of view on what
humanity is or ought to be or should be
it isn't and if you read that book
perhaps a lot of what is happening there
today would be understood all I can say
nobody has won in India in Afghanistan
nobody will Lord Curzon on the third
expedition being mounted for the Afghan
said if you go ahead with this you will
bankrupt the British Empire and believe
me neither America nor anyone else in
the world today had the resources of the
British Empire where the Sun never set
and that exactly is what is happening
today even here you cannot I remember
when they Center up these twenty
thousand pound Daisy cutters and when we
actually got photographs reports where
they were dropping them the little cow
shed attached hot and they'd be dropping
twenty thousand pounds on that because
there was nothing to hit there's nothing
in those mountains to hit and the
question was and this is what I said
recently at the United Nations that when
the Russians came the Americans
of Hana stands friends the Americans
don't seem to realize that now that
they're there they're the enemy and I
was telling the Indians if you go in
your friends now you will become the
enemy is that's why we stay at the side
of the border it's just not worth being
in Afghanistan you can never be a friend
in Afghanistan and that is going to
remain I believe there are five new huge
Controlman being made and the level of
construction is not for Afghan soldiers
and they're meant to house 10,000 troops
each that's 50,000 troops which would be
the bottom line of what you're going to
have to maintain there for a very long
time Wall Street collapse
notwithstanding and in any case Wall
Street collapse because 1.5 trillion was
up in leveraging and hedging I believe
the figure has gone to 2.5 trillion now
so it might not quite be the blame we
put on just Afghanistan it was also the
mechanisms triggered off here as far as
India and Pakistan are concerned I think
we're closer
I think we're getting somewhat closer
there is a great amount of talk you've
had more talk in the last six to eight
months than we've had in the last 50
years so there is a silver lining in the
cloud I think both realize it's mutually
assured destruction anyway if we don't
proceed in that direction and I don't
think despite all our obstinacy or
whatever you'd like to call it we're not
going into that direction I think we're
getting closer I think all of this is
going to lead to better conditions I
remember recently when Sheikh Hasina was
here and how to talk with her now they
were worked up about things but these
are small incidents between the various
players in the subcontinent I don't
think it creates and I do think that in
what is now being created in its loose
fashion the resurgence of a show with
Siberian Russia with China with India
with Middle East oil and then the
undiscovered
undetailed minerals of Central Asia and
Afghanistan and maybe parts of
Balochistan and Iran there is a future
70 percent of world trade is going to be
in the Indian Ocean not in the Pacific
not in the Atlantic and I believe also
that it is changing phenomenally today
40 cents to the dollar is backed by
Asian giants funding America maybe this
is a part of international trade maybe
it's a part of living with each other so
it's great why not and I believe that
many things can be averted through a
global strategy but with a strategy that
is going to be made not just in pristine
atmospheres here but also understanding
it's just not the same it's just not the
same even when you speak of economics
remember the fear I was just quoting a
professor of Columbia and other things
he said is well you know they applied he
could economics can be applied where the
standards and where the markers are
identifiable what you do in places where
the regional thrusts are so powerful and
strong that you just cannot understand
them and you cannot even compare them or
you cannot even identify how you're
going to make this out to be so a little
bit of leeway a little bit of
understanding of each other's positions
a little bit of making sure that when
you put in an institution I think MIT
did the best they put the surrogate into
India 45 years ago and the result is
today phenomenal and I believe we can
achieve that because there is a
fundamental understanding between
Western society have a subcontinent with
that having taken too much of your time
I'm gonna thank you for letting me be
here
and go all over the place with you but
that is more interesting than being cut
and dried from a paper that it just
could be passed on to you to read anyway
thank you thank you very much ambassador